that's the two of them
oh yeah
I'm sorry come on how are you
thank you
oh thank you
foreign
foreign
good afternoon everyone
apologies for being late I had a um my
meeting with the president of the oval
went long so I apologize
okay
yeah I have I was just about to say just
give me a second Darlene I have a super
super short thing at the top and then we
can get straight to questions uh so
today marks the first day of national
flu vaccine week as flu and covid-19
continue increasing in circulation we
have two safe and effective vaccines
that are are our best way to to stay
protected this winter the simple message
from our health and medical expert is
this to be protected this winter get
your flu and coveted shots today Dr
wilinski held a briefing with the
American Medical Association to kick off
a week where she and doctors across the
country will be blitzing the airwaves
about the importance of getting your
covet and flu shots and with that
Darlene go for it thank you can you give
us a rundown on what is being done at
the federal level to speed up the uh the
restoration of electrical power to the
folks in North Carolina so um as you
know the White House is monitoring has
been monitoring the situation and is in
contact with local officials local law
enforcement is receiving Federal support
on the investigation we will continue to
let that investigation play out
President Biden has made as you all know
critical infrastructure secure and
resilience to all hazards both natural
and man-made a priority since the first
day of his administration while we still
have a long way to go through
initiatives like the bipartisan
infrastructure Bill and also the infra
the inflation reduction act the the
Biden Harris Administration is already
flowing through on its prop following
through on its promise to deliver those
results to protect against the limit and
the limit of the impacts of incidents
like this we've closely worked with
private sector to strengthen resilience
against the full spectrum of potential
threats including through utilizing new
technologies and improving
how government communicates and shares
threat information with the private
sector which owns the majority of our
nation's critical infrastructure
Department of energy Department of uh of
Justice including the FBI are will be
your best place to get more specific
information but again we're going to let
we're going to let the investigation
play out but on the issue of restoring
power authorities there are saying it
could be until Thursday before power is
restored understood we have been we have
been in touch with local officials and
and we are we're going to provide any
assistance needed to to help them on the
ground
yeah thanks green um on Friday you said
there were no plans of going to Congress
or any legislative changes to the IRA
for France in Europe uh over the weekend
there were some French officials who
said uh that as one way of making tweaks
that President Biden proposed to the IRA
was through executive orders and we're
wondering if the Administration has
already started working on on you know
certain EOS or if you're planning to
work on them going forward can you offer
any specific so there's two things
um the first thing is the president was
clear that there are ways that we can
address Europe's concerns right the
concerns that they actually have this is
a matter we are working through
substantive consultation with Europe our
European counterparts we don't want to
get ahead of that process but we're
going to have those conversations and
find ways to again address their
concerns I was speaking to specifically
like glitches that might be that we have
taught that we have heard about in
particular in this particular piece of
this law now and so what I was saying no
there are no uh there are there we don't
have plans to go back to Congress on
that on that but when it comes to uh
their concerns of course we're going to
have conversations with our European
allies specifically on that I mean the
administration did say during the French
president's visit that you know that it
had worked on overcoming French
objections to whatever it is that they
were talking about in with respect to
the IRA but the Administration has again
of course not released any specifics on
that and I know you're talking about you
know having future conversations with
them but could you talk about the work
that has gone in so far so not going to
get into specifics again we want to have
this conversation there's a process
that's happening don't want to get ahead
of that but I also just want to say and
you've heard us say this many times you
know the inflation reduction Act was a
historic piece of legislation it's going
to help Americans millions of Americans
across the country as we talk about
lowering cost as we talk talk about
really attacking one of the number one
priority when you think about the
economy for the president which is
lowering costs on Health Care lowering
costs on energy doing that doing that
historic investment on fighting climate
change so this is something that the
president is very proud of and it's
going to really truly change lives when
it comes to the concerns of our European
uh partners and and allies certainly
we're going to do our best to have those
conversations but I'm just not going to
get ahead of the process that's
currently happening Russian on the oil
price Gap
um obviously Russia has said that you
know they're not going to abide by it
even if that means cutting production
Ukraine is saying sixty dollars is way
too much you know Russian organs are
selling in Asian markets at 79 a barrel
which is like 20 dollars
higher per barrel and which kind of
shows that there's willingness to buy
oil from Russia at that price I mean
given all the work that is going in how
confident are you that this is going to
actually have any impact at all on
Moscow and President Putin's whatever so
a couple of things you you just asked me
a couple questions all at once or made a
couple of statements all at once so when
it comes to Russia's response look we're
not surprised by that we're not
surprised uh by what their their
reaction their reaction has been and
what they're saying look the goal of the
price cap has always been to ensure that
discounted Russian oil continues to flow
onto Global markets and even as we limit
the energy Revenue that Russia is using
to fund its illegal war in Ukraine and
so we we believe uh we believe that uh
the the cap at this level maintains
clear incentives for Russia to continue
exporting not doing so would have
serious repercussions for Russia and so
that's how we see this process moving
forward I know that you were mentioning
uh why 30 and not 60 and I I know that
there's been some comments out there and
so look the price the price will lock in
a discount on Russian oil especially in
light of the hundred dollars per barrel
they earned just a few months ago and it
can be adjusted over time to prevent
Russia from further profiting uh from
its war and so this is we believe uh
this isn't uh you know this is an
unprecedented action that we're seeing
right now and it demonstrates the the
unity that United States and our allies
and partners have and I think this is we
think this is an important step forward
okay history any meeting with the
president did he indicate that he'd made
any Headway to his lunch with Senators
Leahy and Shelby about reaching and made
it on the top line before the end of us
so don't have uh don't have any um
readout for you on the president's uh
the president's uh lunch uh as you just
mentioned just first for folks who may
not be aware uh the president had lunch
today with Senators Leahy and Shelby of
the Senate Appropriations Committee to
toast their long careers but also to
your point uh Phil to discuss uh the
funding bill look the president believes
that Congress needs to and and has to
reach a deal a bipartisan deal this is
something that they were able to do just
last year around this time in a
bipartisan way he believes that they
should be able to do this again this
should not be about partisanship we are
talking about critical uh critical
funding when you think about Public
public education when you think about
our national security when you think
about uh you know about health these are
important things that are that are
critical to the American people so he
believes that we should the Congress
should move forward in getting this done
but more broadly speaking and I settled
this last week uh when it comes to our
efforts and and uh and and the funding
we and how we're moving forward we
believe that process is in good hands uh
with our OMB director Shalonda young she
knows how to get this done she knows how
to get a bipartisan uh deal uh get that
done and also
um you know we have our office of ledge
Affairs who is working on this as well
they have been we've had you know
multiple conversations with member of
Congress and we'll continue to make
calls we continue to do briefings but
again this is something that the
president believes needs to get done it
was done last year in a bi-person way we
should be able to do that this year is
the president is he showed any openness
to the idea of dropping the parity
between defense spending and non-defense
domestic spending which is currently the
Republican so look I'll say this
um you know I'm not going to get ahead
of any uh discussions that are currently
happening uh right now and so I know the
Congress is moving forward having those
discussion I'm certainly uh not going to
be negotiating from here from the podium
if I can uh the Supreme Court heard
arguments today about
excites for gay
galaxies seem to be sympathetic toward
her uh in today's uh on the court today
we've heard the White House talk about
the potential Ripple effects after the
Dobbs ruling do you have a comment on
this specific case and any concerns from
the administration about the potential
wider implications of this particular
case so I want to be very careful here
don't want to weigh in or prejudge the
Supreme the Supreme Court's outcome you
know that's something I'm going to do
here at the podium but to your point
more broadly speaking and we have talked
about this we recognize the uh the right
to free speech and we support ensuring
that no one is discriminated against or
refused services because of who they
love and who they are and so as you know
we've been very clear about that the
administration believes that every
person no matter their sex race religion
or who they love should have the equal
access to society including access to
products and services on the same terms
as other members of public look
Department of Justice said in its brief
that for decades non-discrimination
public accommodations laws have
coexisted with the First Amendment uh
courts have recognized that we can
recognize that we can require businesses
open to public to service people
regardless of their backgrounds even
when that means businesses must
incidentally
engage in speech which they are which
they disagree upon so this is no reason
to upend this balance right now uh as
the as the Department of Justice just
laid out as I just laid out what their
uh what they said in their brief but
again I don't want to weigh in I don't
want to get ahead of of what the Supreme
Court's decision will be on this and on
the uh year-end wish list and to-do list
is there a push right now by the White
House to renew the expanded child tax
credit I don't have anything new to
share on on that uh particular uh
particular piece of of um of legislation
or or piece of a plan that that's
incredibly important to the president as
you know he included in the American
Rescue plan and it was a it was able to
cut a child child poverty in a historic
way uh so uh again important issue for
this President don't have anything to
share uh to to share further on uh on
any on that particular plan moving
forward okay
thanks Kareem uh I wonder if you could
give more detail about the Wednesday
event about the rise of anti-Semitism uh
that's hosted by the second gentleman
are you gonna call him the first time
slipped up
uh how long has it been in the works and
what do you hope Mister what does the
White House hope Mr imhoff adds to the
debate so a couple of things just to
give you some insight of what's going to
be happening uh with that with the round
table talks the anti-Semitism raw table
talks like the second gentleman uh will
be uh we'll be hosting so first and
foremost President Biden has
consistently spoken out I just want to
make sure that's clear against
anti-semitis anti-Semitism it's rhetoric
it's hate and all of the vile language
that we have been hearing which is
incredibly dangerous uh this past couple
of weeks and so we're going to continue
condemning anti-Semitism and hate
wherever it exists it does not have it
should not have a place in our society
and so you'll you'll continue to hear
that the President says silence is
complicit complicity and so uh you know
that is something that we will make sure
that we continue to condemn now as it
relates to Wednesday the second
gentleman Douglas emhoff will convene a
Roundtable with Jewish leaders from
across the country tree the round table
will include leaders of Jewish
organizations fighting anti-Semitism
that represents the wide range of Jewish
Community from students to seniors and
including reform conservative and
Orthodox denominations and the second
gentleman will be joined by Ambassador
Susan Rice White House domestic policy
advisor Ambassador Deborah lipstead a
special Envoy to Monitor and combat
anti-Semitism and Keisha Lance bottom
senior advisor to the president for
public engagement he felt it was
important to host the Roundtable given
the rise as I just was mentioning of
anti-Semitism that we have seen over the
past several months and even longer this
is something the second gentleman takes
very personally he is the first Jewish
person in this role the first Jewish
individual married to a president or a
vice president he has said himself that
he is in pain and that this is something
we cannot normalize and that's one of
the reasons as I just laid out that he
wanted to do this personally just to
follow can is it something that he asked
for or something that the president
directed them to do well I just laid out
the president has has been very clear
and condemning anti-Semitism the hate
that we have been seeing racism uh the
increase of hatred that we've been
seeing just the past several months so
this is something that his
administration more broadly is going to
continue to do when we talk about
condemning that type of speech but look
I just laid out this is something when
it comes to this round table that the
second gentleman is holding it's
something that's is very personal to him
and important for him that he believed
that he needed to do and uh clearly you
know it's part of the art
administration's response and certainly
we welcome we'll welcome it it's green
uh to follow up a little bit on that the
week ahead after Wednesday there were no
public events for the president if
that's we can take a more Hands-On
approach to the spending deal if
necessary and can we expect him to drop
by that anti-Semitism Roundtable on
Wednesday it's a good question I don't
have anything to preview at this time on
uh on if you'll be able to stop by uh
clearly we're always working through the
present schedule as you know but just to
lay out uh the president's engagement on
on the as as we're discussing the
government funding uh bill look as you
know he had the big four here last week
in leadership to talk about they talked
about this you saw it in the readout he
met with uh with President Leahy and and
president pardon me Senator Senators
Leahy and Shelby to have the discussion
about the Omnibus Bill and so the
president is going to continue to have
those conversations he's going to
continue to be involved I don't have
anything to preview at this time on uh
on what the rest of his schedule is
going to look like for the week it
pretends to Wednesday also could we
expect remarks from him regardless of
what happens in Georgia on Wednesday and
then lastly the president he didn't end
up going to Georgia during the the
campaign to campaign for Rafael Warnock
he hasn't been during the runoff
election but why is that so look
um I need to be careful the Hatch Act
this is an ongoing as you know
um uh election with this particular what
we're seeing the runoff in in Georgia so
I want to be really careful here but I
have said many times before at this
Podium that the president will do
anything that that he can do for Senator
Warner to be helpful to him as you all
seen on the president's schedule
recently he's done a high volume of
fundraising attended several uh
political events including phone Banks
and unions and much and and with unions
and much more look the way that we see
this if you think about the midterms
that just occurred the president played
a big role here he set the narrative on
how Democrats were going to move forward
in the midterms how they were going to
talk about the successes that they had
how they how they were going to talk
about what was important uh to American
families right they made that contrast
uh with Republican electives Republican
officials who were talking about uh
getting rid of Social Security and
putting that on The Chopping Block
putting Medicare on The Chopping Block
uh he talked about the freedoms of of
the American people wanted as it relates
to Roe v Wade and how we saw the Supreme
Court get rid of Roe and we talked about
that and how Republicans wanted to put a
national ban they were pushing for a
national ban and it didn't matter which
states if you're a red or blue State and
this is the thing that the president
talked about and others followed so the
president played a big role in setting
that narrative setting that contrast and
let's not forget the successes that we
have seen his Economic Policy successes
as we talk about the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation uh the
influence inflation reduction Act those
are the things that the president was
able to get done and Democrats were able
to run on it
of course been a harsh season for
Respiratory illnesses in children and
there continue to be anecdotal reports
that some drugs are in short supply in
certain places like Children's Tylenol
ibuprofen amoxicillin the supply chain
is clearly under duress and some
Americans are struggling to find the
drugs they need what's the
administration doing about it and how
big of an issue do you believe it is so
first I would refer you to the FDA who
was keeping a close eye on this and they
will share more on any details about
supplies as it relates to concerns on
drugs which are laying out to me Ben but
I'll what I'll say more broadly on this
is for contacts is that drug shortages
are not uncommon and is something the
administration is regularly monitoring
the FDA is always tracking shortages at
the national level and works closely
with manufacturers to understand their
production and supply and while FDA does
not manufacture drugs and cannot require
a pharmaceutical company to make to make
a drug make a more of a drug or change
the distribution of a drug FDA is in
touch with the various manufacturers and
stand ready to provide support with
where possible again this is something
that we are monitoring I would refer you
to the FDA on any specifics considering
stepping in and working with companies
in any way similar to how you all did
with the baby formula shortage I don't
have anything more to share on on any
type of Outreach but again FDA would be
the best place for you to uh to get more
details on on how they're moving forward
with this okay would you Curry
Administration decided whether to appeal
the Court ruling that ends title 42
because the deadline is this week so
I've been asked this question a couple
times in the briefing room this is
something that uh because it's a legal
matters something that the Department of
Justice will decide on and I would leave
it to them we understand that the
administration is considering a proposal
that would bar certain migrants from
receiving Asylum here in the U.S if they
don't seek asylum in other countries
first is that a proposal that you're
moving forward with or are there any
other alternative measures to title 42
on the table so look we are committed to
continuing uh to secure our borders
while maintaining safe orderly and
Humane process processing of migrants
that is something that we are committed
to in under this Administration this
will remain the case with title 42 one
title 42 is lifted any suggestions that
we might be changing a policy or looking
at a different policy is is inaccurate
at this time I know there's been
conversations about that we haven't made
any no such decisions have been made yet
but again we are committed to securing
our border
questions on this um Chinese hack right
the group apt-41 The Secret Service says
that this
state-sponsored group of cyber criminals
stole at least 20 million dollars in
covid relief including small business
administration loans
Insurance funds what safeguards are in
place to prevent this sort of Fraud and
why did they fail is my first question
so look we we don't comment uh on
specific Law Enforcement cases uh so
clearly not going to do that from the
podium but the president has continually
embraced and called for strong oversight
and enforcement against potential fraud
the president made clear that in the
State of the Union his State of the
Union just earlier this year and when he
announced the Justice Department's
appointment of a chief prosecutor for
pandemic fraud as part of the
interagency covid-19 a fraud enforcement
task force so for for more on any
specifics on this or any more details
like again this is a legal enforcement
matter this is something that Department
of Justice would report to reduce any
consequences again this is something
that the Department of Justice would be
dealing with as it is in ongoing law
enforcement matter
on the trip tomorrow president bond has
visited a lot of semiconductor plants
what can you just talk about what makes
this one special is it you know based on
that it's run by Taiwan uh Taiwan
company uh is it Advanced chips what
what's kind of differentiates this this
trip so it's a very good question we are
going to be having a background call uh
to this evening at 6 30 which is going
to be led by Brian deese and so I would
encourage all of you to join that
background call and you'll have more
specifics
I'm sorry a backgrounder backgrounder
yes it's a backgrounder uh and it'll as
you know it's usually lifted uh the next
morning so yes it is a background call
with Brian dies that'll happen at 6 30.
so again I'll encourage all of you to
join uh but look you know as you know
he's going to be going to Phoenix
Arizona to be discussing uh the American
manufacturing under this President we
have seen uh Emmanuel American
manufacturing coming back to the U.S and
a lot of that is because of the
president's economic policies we've seen
more than 700 000 manufacturing jobs
created under this President and he is
going to continue to talk about that
talk about the chips and science act and
that historic piece of legislation that
was as you all know a bipartisan piece
of legislation that is going to continue
making sure that we have manufacturing
jobs right here in the U.S so again
you'll get more details on that don't
want to get ahead of that conversation
that will be had by Brian deese at 7 7
30 it's a background call I again
encourage all of you to join yeah that's
great two questions for you first on the
North Carolina power outage the local
authorities have said they believe it's
an intentional attack is the White House
aware of any motive that might have been
behind that again I'm just not going to
get ahead of the process it is being
looked at investigated currently not go
I'm going to let that investigation play
out I would refer you to the Department
of energy Department of Justice FBI to
get any more specific details on that
and then uh Democratic leaders in the
house are discussing attaching Senator
manchin's permitting Bill to the annual
defense policy bill which is a must pass
is the White House urging that too and
uh if so how are you doing that so yes
uh the president believes we should pass
the defensive authorization Bill and
that the permitting bill should be
included in that legislation so that is
something that we support from here
other things on the to-do list the
antitrust Tech bill was the president
want to see action on that I don't have
anything more to say than what I shared
uh last week I refer you back to to I
was asked about this couple times last
week sorry for you back to those
comments thanks the Electoral count act
reform is that something that is
something that is indeed important uh to
the president he wants to see that move
forward
uh the there was word today of an
agreement in principle between Senators
Tillis and Cinema on immigration reform
is that something so we haven't seen all
of the kind of the language on that
particular bill so don't want to comment
from here I don't want to get it too far
ahead I know there's a draftive proposal
uh but look the president has repeatedly
called on Congress to permanently
protect dreamers Farm Workers essential
workers and others and to provide them
with the pathway to citizenship remember
the first day of his uh his
administration he put forth a a
comprehensive immigration bill so we are
committed to working with members of
Congress from both parties on real
solutions to modernize and uh our
outdated immigration system so that is
certainly a priority for the president
but we haven't seen the detailed
proposals I can't comment from about
that from here one thing Senator Shaheen
has a statement she's apparently not
coming to the ball tonight
she's upset that the president endorsed
the proposal to put South Carolina in
New Hampshire and she says that New
Hampshire is now vulnerable for her
party uh which does the president have a
response to that so look um we on we
honor the Hatch Act as I as I mentioned
many times before here as we are talking
about a potential election a 2020 for uh
presidential election but Looking
Backward it is the ultimate irony uh you
know uh that the 2020 election was was
uh was proven by the Trump
administration's Homeland oh sorry I
think I got ahead of myself there
we take the law very seriously here and
so that's the number one thing and again
I want to be very careful because of
2024 and it places strict limits on what
I I can say because of the Hatch Act
about future elections and of course
political party processes I know I was
asked this question many times before
about the DNC and so I've always
referred folks to go to the DNC but
again as a candidate in 2020 and as we
have heard the night of the New
Hampshire primary Joe Biden was very
clear that to him respecting our
diversity as a nation and breaking down
barriers for our people is a fundamental
principle and and so he believes that
what Democrats in office stand for and
he has upheld that Principle as
president and so again you've seen him
do that throughout his almost two years
in administration making sure that we
see the diversity within his
administration that is represented
clearly across across the country and he
wants to honor those values and so
that's as far as I'm going to get from
here about the specific uh calendar
again don't want to get into
Politics as it relates to political
parties
talk about with Congress considering uh
repealing the covet vaccine mandate for
service members in the ndaa uh John
Kirby spoke earlier about the
president's position secretary Austin's
position of wanting obviously to keep it
so what is the White House prepared to
do for that aspect of it and is the
president personally engaging with
lawmakers on this so look when when the
president met with the big four just
last week as you all know
um as you know leader McCarthy raised
eliminating the requirement that service
members be vaccinated against covid-19
so clearly they had a conversation as
you asked me about talking to members
the president told him that he would
consider it but also made clear that he
wanted to consult with the Pentagon and
since then as we've all heard this the
Secretary of Defense has recommended
retaining the Mandate that's because the
covet vaccination requirement was put in
place to keep our service members safe
and healthy and prepared for service and
I would remind you know I remind all of
you that the Pentagon has a range of
vaccines it has long required so this is
nothing new uh again uh this is you know
there's history here there's precedent
so with respect to ndaa those
discussions are ongoing I don't want to
get ahead of it but clearly as I just
mentioned it was meant it was brought up
in their conversation that he had uh
with the big four he asked last week has
he had conversations about it since then
I don't have anything else to preview at
this time for you on conversation
specifically on the ndaa uh I could I
can say that we're just not going to get
ahead of the process that's currently
happening in Congress from the podium
that the white house isn't going to
respond to every single thing but former
president Trump says or does but the
White House also did put out some
statements over the weekend about his
calls to essentially overturn the 2020
election and put aside the Constitution
so I'm wondering if you can elaborate on
that and share more about any response
to his comments so look you know
um and again he is a um
uh he is a declared candidate so want to
be very careful on how I respond to
someone who has declared in 2024 uh but
you know this is what I was trying to
say earlier you know as it relates to
um you know 2020 2020 and election
conspiracy look it's an irony right that
that 2020 election was was uh that he
says this because ultimately uh it was
proven uh by uh by the Trump
administration's Homeland Security
officials to be the most secure of all
time and not just the homeland security
officials it was also upheld by Trump's
administration's attorney general and by
over 80 uh federal judges of whom were
nominated by Donald Trump himself and so
in 2022 the American people came
together just past midterms and utterly
rejected the dangerous conspiracy that
we have been hearing the big lie that we
have been hearing from the former
president but also many Republicans and
so uh look they have been American
people have been very clear uh they uh
they are they oppose the way that
Republicans have talked about this uh
they oppose the violent rhetoric that
extreme Mega officials have engaged in
uh and uh and so we should listen to
what the American people had to say just
a couple weeks ago
okay okay
thanks uh just on Arizona again um is
there another side to this trip uh
political side and Beyond the chips
um aspect uh because he's done a lot of
similar speeches in in future or current
plants
um probably to a lot of Americans
Arizona politically speaking might sound
like that place where they have a lot of
Elections on us so it's fun to have a
hot hot spot politics so I'm not going
to get ahead of the background call
that's going to happen at 6 30. I'm
Gonna Let Brian D speak to why this trip
is so important uh why what TS tsmc's
semiconductor material manufacturing
facility uh is uh is is a big deal
um and so don't again don't want to get
ahead of it I will encourage you to join
the call and you'll you'll hear more
about the president's trip tomorrow okay
but I mean I'm not talking on the chip
side right I know you're asking me if
there is if you're asking me oh because
it's in Arizona yes
weren't you because he's been to a bunch
of places
no I hear your question
no I I hear your question but the
president has said this over and over
again he's a president for uh for
everyone uh whether you live in a you
know red state blue State purple State
uh this is about delivering for the
American people uh this is about keeping
his promises as he moves forward with
his economic policies uh look the chips
and science Act is a historic piece of
legislation that is going to bring and
we're seeing this already uh
manufacturing back uh to the U.S and has
created hundreds of thousands of
manufacturing jobs and so that's why
this is a this is an important uh this
is an important uh move forward that
we're seeing in this with this
particular facility in Arizona and he
wants to highlight that he wants to lift
that up and so I don't want to get ahead
of what uh what the announcements are
going to be or what he's going to talk
specifically about about what we're
going to see at this facility tomorrow
but as you think about politics takes as
you're asking me this question again
this is a president who has been very
very clear he's going to deliver for all
Americans
about the medical I think you've said
previously that part of the medical has
been done already physical exam
um when will the rest of it be done like
very roughly is it by the end of the
year or don't have any any specific
dates to lay out or timeline to lay out
I can say I think I've said this last
week it was going to be in the next few
months we will we will release the
president's uh physical in the same
fashion in the same transparent fashion
as we did last year
Kareen thank you so much Corrine uh this
morning the National Security advisor
met with president-elect of Brazil Lula
for about one hour and 30 minutes uh
what would you highlight from the
meeting in uh also Mr Sullivan invited
uh ruler to the White House before
Lula's inauguration January 1st is that
visit happening and why is the White
House extending this very not very
common invitation uh to ruler even
before he's the president so to your
first question uh they the two of them
had a ride arranging and productive
conversation about how the United States
and and Brazil can continue to work
together to address common challenges
and deepen our strong bilateral
relationship and we will have a fuller
readout of the visit uh his the Jake
Sullivan's visit to Brazil later today
and uh you'll you'll have more details
on that to your last question look we
will have more to share on that soon as
your question into a visit look this is
really important to uh to the president
we have said before we we've been
working with members of incoming Lula's
Administration for face-to-face
engagement that's nothing new we've
talked about that and we at high levels
so that we can hit the ground running
once president-elect Lula becomes
president in in January so this is
something that we have been very clear
about very transparent about again as I
just stated we want to hit the ground
running with that relationship that
important uh bilateral relationship that
we have with Brazil and did the White
House decide who are you guys sending to
the inauguration it's going to be uh the
delegation
uh we'll have we'll have more to share
on what that's going to what that makeup
of the delegation might look like I
don't have anything to share for you at
this time okay
good Queen thank you uh the
administration said they're going to
refill the Strategic petroleum Reserve
uh under 70 a barrel the Russian price
cap went into effect today 60 a barrel
could is the president considering
putting Russian oil in the Strategic
petroleum Missouri no because it's been
banned okay what about in Arizona I just
want to ask you he's going to that chips
factory any plans in Arizona to go to
the border and see for the situation for
himself there so look I want to be very
clear here the president trips tomorrow
is about the American manufacturing boom
we're seeing all across the country
thanks to again his economic policies
again more than we have seen in his his
uh you know almost two-year term uh more
than 700 000 jobs manufacturing jobs
that have been created just here alone
in the United States so he'll be
visiting at tsmc a company making a
major investment to manufacturing
Cutting Edge chips in Phoenix this
investment will bring new jobs and
Economic Opportunity to Arizona very
important to the people in Arizona and
it's a large part thanks to the chips
and science act the president signed it
to law and a historic let's not forget a
bipartisan piece of legislation and look
we should be able to uh to reach a
bipartisan you know a bipartisan
agreement on immigration too and that's
what we're calling for right we're
asking for Republican officials to come
and work with us and and let's have a
bipartisan agreement on immigration
instead of doing political stunts
instead of doing what they're doing
going to the Border not actually coming
up with any real ideas about that that's
where I will leave it that's what the
president is doing tomorrow is going to
go to Arizona to talk about an important
initiative that's going to change
Americans lives specifically in Arizona
if the president is not going to make
time to visit the order during his trip
to tomorrow during his trip tomorrow to
a border state will he do it in in New
Year look I addressed this last week
about the President visiting the Border
I'm not going to go beyond what I just
laid out I think and we believe the
question again is I was uh just
answering to your colleague in the back
uh is that uh what are congressional
Republicans going to do to actually deal
with this issue instead of doing
political stunts many of their political
stunts that hurt families that hurt kids
that hurt children right that hurt
people who are who are coming here to
try to uh seek Asylum leaving a a uh you
know leaving a dictatorship instead of
going to the border and talking about uh
you know about things that not going to
actually deliver and keep our border
safe why don't they work with us why
don't they actually do something why
don't they actually uh you know help the
president get the funding that that he
requested historic funding to uh into
Homeland into the Department of Homeland
Security uh that's one way of doing that
but again they're playing political
games and doing political stunts
the reason I asked is just because the
president had said previously that he
hadn't had a lot of time to get to the
Border he's gone to a border state
tomorrow so you think maybe there would
be time there
um if there isn't tomorrow
can you say at this point that he what
I'm saying is tomorrow he's going to
actually focus on an issue a bipartisan
issue that was voted in Congress the
chips and science acts something that is
going to deliver for the people in
Arizona uh creating jobs and making
people's lives better and making sure
that we are bringing manually factoring
back into the US that is critically
important now what I'm saying the second
part of that to your question if
Republicans officials truly truly want
to deal with immigration they truly want
to deal with the Border then they would
stop doing political stunts and actually
work with us on the plan that we have
put forward which they are not and
that's what we want to make very loud
and clear there's ways to deal with this
again they can come and actually do this
in a bipartisan way just like we did
with the chips and science Act the trip
was obviously to Phoenix
not to the Border not to Georgia
um which is sort of a pressing issue for
for democrats for the president have
Democrats determined that a visit uh to
Georgia would not help Senator warnock's
re-election bid the president actually
and I actually already answered this and
I'll just repeat what I just said
um the president when and I want to be
very careful about talking about an
election that's happening tomorrow
because it's an ongoing it's an election
and I have I'm covered on the The Hatch
Act so I'm not going to comment on that
specifically but when I when we look
back on the president's role during the
midterm elections he played a
significant role for Democrats it was
because again I just answered this
question is because of the way he made
the contrast with Republican officials
again who wanted to put who who talked
about putting Social Security and
Medicare on The Chopping Block because
they were upset about the inflation
reduction act which is a historic piece
of legislation is going to lower costs
for American families that's what they
were upset about because we were saying
we wanted to make sure big corporations
pay their fair share and not put it on
uh the little guy and and that's what
they put forward and the American people
were very we spoke really loud and clear
that's not what they want they want us
to continue to fight for their freedoms
they want us to continue to fight for
democracy and you know that Red Wave
never happened
just real quick on Twitter because you
guys said you're keeping a close eye on
Elon musk's ownership and the person
we've talked to you since you released
the files uh a few days ago is it the
White House view that decisions at
Twitter were made appropriately uh in
terms of
decisions to censor this reporting ahead
of the election you uh
you mischaracterized actually what I
what I actually said to get out of
context when you asked her a question
um look when I answered the question and
I already I actually already addressed
this
um about uh how the the the White House
and the administration is is seeing
what's happening on Twitter we were we
follow also uh what's going on just like
you guys are reporting just like you
guys are seeing and what I was
commenting to is like yes we're we're
seeing what is happening just like you
all are seeing what's happening with
Twitter so just want to clear that up
because you definitely mischaracterize
what I said or put it out of context
um and so can you ask your question
again yes my question was that you had
said I think six or so days ago that the
White House was watching
um closely the situation at Twitter
after Elon musk's ownership of it with
risked back to misinformation and
because these files were released
um on the basis of you know
hack materials Clause at Twitter
decisions were made to censor reporting
leading up to the election my question
was is it the White House view that
these decisions were made appropriately
in light of what has come out
which Decisions by whom by Twitter by
Twitter on okay so look
we see this as a an interesting or a
coincidence if I may that that he would
so haphazardly uh Twitter was so
haphazardly pushed this distraction that
is a that is a full of old news if you
think about it and at the same time
Twitter is facing very real and very
serious questions about the rising
volume of anger hate and anti-Semitism
on their platform and how they're
letting it happen and you know the
president said last week more leaders
need to speak out and reject this and
it's a very alarming and very dangerous
and but our Focus right now is helping
the American families that just talked
about what the president is going to be
doing in Arizona talking about the chips
and science act talking about how we're
bringing manufacturing jobs back here to
the us talking about under this
Administration more than 700 000 jobs
have been created
in manufacturing jobs to be more
specific look what is happening it's
it's not it's is frankly it's not
healthy it won't do anything to help a
single American improve their lives and
so look this isn't we we see this that
is an interesting uh you know cons uh
you know coincidence uh and uh and you
know it's a distraction
in the range of about 10 billion over
five years does the White House have a
position on that and is there any
concern that providing additional
security assistance to Taiwan might act
as a nerd in a relationship with Chuck
so look not going to get ahead of the
process as it relates to in Congress
or the ndaa I'll say this more broadly
we continue to work with Congress on
ways we can reinforce deterrence across
the Taiwan Strait and build taiwan's
resilience in meaningful ways including
the self-defense capabilities but again
I'm not going to get ahead of the
process that we're currently seeing in
Congress at this time all right
everybody thanks everybody oh what do I
what's going on
okay I'll take that let me just do this
and I'll
okay we have a guest
[Applause]
okay so we are pleased to have a local
reporter uh from the Arizona Republic
and Arizona Central join us uh in the
briefing room today and uh ahead of the
president's trip as we've been talking
about Arizona and the chips and science
act uh his name is Ronald J Henson he is
the papers National political reporter
and has been a member of their team for
about 15 years and uh Ron thank you for
joining us hello
yeah hi thanks Karine um as you know the
tsmc plant was announced in 2020 so uh
one of the no uh a couple things number
one what should ordinary Americans
expect that is attributable to the chips
act uh how soon should they be seeing
the effects of that in Arizona or
elsewhere and also in the long run
should the government be playing uh any
greater role in providing more water
resources to a place like Arizona in uh
in light of this water intensive
industry so on your first question um
Ronald
um I would refer you to the Department
of Commerce as timeline they're working
on this and they're playing point when
it comes to the chips and science act on
your final question it's important that
these facilities are built sustainably
and and in a way that doesn't harm the
environment of a region we know that
these chip Fabs can be water intensive
but both tsmc and Intel have taken steps
to reduce water usage at their
facilities in Arizona in the case of
tsmc they have planned on a site
industrial Water Reclamation plant that
will significant reduce significantly
reduce liquid discharge within the Biden
Administration it is an issue we takes
very seriously as evidenced by funding
for Arizona drought resiliency resources
including included in the inflation
reduction act as you know Ronald and as
these projects continue State officials
local officials will in will need to
take this issue seriously as they work
with chip makers and build in their
region and so there you go Ronald thank
you so much for joining us on uh I know
there was a question on the summit we
will have more we will we will have we
will have more to share in the next
couple of days yes the U.S Summit is
incredibly important we have invited 49
African heads of state to Washington DC
for a three-day Summit to highlight how
the U.S and African nations are
strengthening our Partnerships to
Advanced shared priorities the summit
reflects the U.S strategy towards sub
Saharan Africa which emphasizes the
critical importance of the region to
meet this era's defining challenges
again we will have more to share on the
upcoming days I gotta go guys thank you
so much
foreign